bonsoir nicolas giraud merci d'être avec
nous la france qui refusera donc de
s'engager dans un accord qui en l'état
contribue à la déforestation et au
réchauffement climatique mais la
pression de l'europe est trop forte
c'est ça mais ça y ressemble en tout cas
ça y ressemble c'est à dire que on avait
bien entendu emmanuel macron le le 14
décembre de vacances citoyennes pour le
climat dire que le mercosur
il ne passerait pas il ne signerait pas
il viendrait le il viendrait combattre
au niveau européen et on est
complètement la dent dans l'ue en même
temps c'est à dire que on n'en veut pas
mais en même temps on continue à
négocier on négocie des déclarations
annexes qui semble-t-il amènerez
quelques avancées sur le climat sur les
normes sanitaires etc
sauf que on sait qu'à chaque fois les
déclarations annexes à ce genre
d'accords sont totalement dévoyé et très
peu appliquée est difficilement
applicable à chaque fois donc on est on
va en nounou nous on est très très mal à
l'aise par rapport à ce qui est en train
de se jouer parce que on est en train
d'accepter une fois de plus de mettre en
concurrence le monde paysan français et
européen avec le reste du monde et de se
dire que ben voilà 6e on peut continuer
à exporter nos voitures et nos services
pourquoi pas remettre les paysans
français et européen en concurrence avec
ceux avec ceux d'amérique du sud avant
travie paris cherche t'il vraiment à
renégocier ou va-t-il ratifié le traité
en l'état dans le fond quel est votre
plus grande inquiétude sur quoi vous ne
céderez pas mais nous toute façon on
cédera pas sur le fait de signer ce
genre d'accord à la confédération
paysanne on s'est toujours opposé au
préalable déjà aux accords de l'om c'est
comme il était posée puis aux accords de
libre échange bilatéraux comme ils sont
rares et signé su avec le canada le ceta
ce avec le mercosur qui sont en train
d'être discuté avec la nouvelle zélande
ce avec l'afrique de l'ouest
des accords qui sont désastreux pour les
paysanne les paysans de france est
d'aider et des pays avec qui on signe
également pour l' enjeu de souveraineté
alimentaire sur nos différents
continents
parce que on est toujours en train de le
concurrencer et de tirer vers le bas les
productions c'est à celui qui s'assoira
le lieu sur ces normes sociales
environnementales sanitaires qui
remportera ces marchés et cette course
aux prix bas et donc c'est complète pour
des fastes à tout à l'alimentation à la
relocalisation au climat et à
l'installation paysage il en nombreux
donc nous on s'oppose j'allais dire on
baise peu sourd non seulement en l'état
mais dans sa globalité on s'oppose aussi
que de facto où on continue à réouvrir
les négociations en disant que le bas si
on peut par le passé par la porte grande
ouverte on va passer par la fenêtre en
catimini nous jaillir de l'un ou l'autre
on est opposé à ce genre d'acte
clairement nicolas giraud quelles
seraient les conséquences pour vous
paysan français
les conséquences les conséquences elles
seraient elles seraient assez dramatique
notamment pour l'élevage on cible
beaucoup l'élevage de viande bovine
on parle aussi de la volaille ou y
aurait des importations qui seraient
massives sur sur les années et sur les
années qui suivraient cet accord là
selon une étude de la commission
européenne donc c'est pas une étude de
la confédération paysanne ou ou de ou
d'organisations opposé à l'accord selon
une étude de la commission européenne
d'ici à 2030 les les importations de
boeuf et de volaille
elle augmenterait sur le continent
européen entre 20 et 30% en boeufs et
envola est à peu près sûr sur ces
volumes là et ces augmentations extrait
du pour 44%
sur le boeuf au mercosur et pour 37% sur
les volailles au mercosur
ça veut dire que on aurait des
augmentations d'importation absolument
dramatique absolument massive sur des
secteurs qui sont déjà en grande
difficulté sur des secteurs on n'arrive
pas à rémunérer les paysans où on
n'arrive pas à engager la transition des
modèles agricoles pour les rendre plus
vertueux écologiquement plus vertueux
climatiquement et sur des modèles où on
nous le monde également de travailler à
la relocalisation à dire que l'on voit
pendant que cette crise sanitaire qu en
train de vivre la crise qu vide que
l'enjeu de la relocalisation quelque
chose de majeur qui est question les
lèvres de la plupart de nos politiques
mais quand on nous met en face de cet
enjeu de relocalisation les accords de
libre échange et la concurrence avec des
volumes à prix bas qui arriverait c'est
absolument impossible à la pensée à la
mettre en place et et à la rendre
effective
donc c'est c'est absolument dramatique
c'est à dire que on est dans des choses
qui se pose complètement et on nous
demande des choses complètement
différentes
en même temps donc c'est impossible à
mettre en oeuvre et on se rend compte
que ce qui va se passer c'est que les
paysanne les paysans français les
éleveurs et les éleveuses français vont
continuer à voir leurs revenus baisser
vont continuer à disparaître vous
continuez à pas réussir à renouveler
leur ferme
donc on va voir des fermes qui
s'agrandissent qui s'intensifie à des
territoires qui se spécialise qui se
sait réalise dès qu'on va voir un
élevage qui va disparaître petit à petit
merci beaucoup aux nicolas giraud porte
parole de la confédération paysanne
merci d'avoir été avec nous